Saturn was one of the most radical
innovations in work organization of the
last several decades but it was not
alone so let's take a look at a number
of companies that are proof of concept
that you can compete with what we call
high road strategies with good jobs that
provide good returns to shareholders by
using what we call human capital that is
essentially workers skills and their
social networks to drive innovation good
jobs and high performance for the
organization let's start with one that I
think almost everyone knows Southwest
Airlines this is an airline that was
created in the 1970s and it's been an
anomaly to our friends on Wall Street
Southwest has been one of the most
profitable airlines in the United States
over the last thirty years yet at the
same time it breaks a lot of rules first
of all it's been roundly criticized by
Wall Street for not in not expanding
fast enough not growing fast enough but
using its retained earnings to share
them but more equitably with their
employees than growing in the airline
secondly it's highly unionized airline
wall street thinks unions are a drag
third it has the best customer service
of any airline in the country and it
builds that customer service by engaging
employees in successful ways and it has
continued to be successful even after
the retirement of its charismatic
founder the CEO Herb Kelleher we're now
on the fourth CEO at Southwest and it
continues to do well and so Southwest
does get good ratings from its employees
and now even it gets good ratings from
Wall Street so this is from a glass door
survey where employees can voluntarily
offer their assessment of their
companies and their CEO and you can see
that Southwest is ranked number one in
the country in terms of a place to work
so we can do this we can make companies
design companies that are successful
for employees by listening to them by
engaging them by engaging in the
teamwork that Southwest provides as well
as producing high quality services and
highly profitable companies but
Southwest is not alone let's dig a
little bit deeper and understand what
the difference is between a high road
and a low road company let's do that by
first looking at Walmart and then
comparing it to another company called
Costco as you know Walmart is the
largest employer in the United States it
has over 1.2 million quote associates
they like to use the term associates to
describe their employees Walmart has
been successful financially yet Walmart
has the tightest controls on its
employees it gets its financial success
by having as you know a motto of low
prices all the time how does it get
those low prices by having very low wage
rates by controlling employees by having
high turnover so employees don't become
more expensive it has no unions and in
fact it fights unions tooth and nail to
make sure it stays non-union so here's a
company that works for shareholders but
is very tough on its employees but then
compare that to Costco Costco competes
with some of Walmart stores that are
called Sam Club and Costco has a very
different model it emphasizes product
quality it emphasizes customer service
it pays wages that are higher than
Walmart it allows employees to unionize
if that's what they choose to do so some
of their stores are unionized and some
are not it has a very long tenure of its
employees because they learn about the
business and they become more productive
over time and so here we have two
alternatives we have a high road
employer called Costco we have a low
road employer called Walmart both can be
reasonably successful financially but
only one can be successful financially
and provide good jobs and good
opportunities for its employees and in
fact this chart shows that Costco has
outperformed Walmart on financial
in recent years and so there are two
ways to compete there's a low road
there's a high road let's review just
how do you get these high road practices
how can you build companies that are
successful for both investors for
employees and for customers well it
starts by selecting employees both for
technical skills and for teamwork skills
so that they're ready to work together
effectively with their colleagues
secondly it requires continuous training
and investment of frontline workers as
well as middle managers and supervisors
it requires us to work together to build
a culture of trust at the workplace to
engage employees and to get them to want
to cooperate with each other to get the
jobs done it requires compensation
systems that align the incentives so
that employees share in the income and
the productivity that they help to
produce by profit sharing or various
kinds of incentive systems
it requires if unionized to have
labor-management partnerships where
labor and management work together and
the union leaders are taken into the
confidence of management representatives
to get the job done together and these
principles apply to organizations not
just in the US but all around the world
recall that we mentioned earlier
companies like Simcoe and Brazil where
employees help design their own jobs and
work in partnership with management to
improve operations and sometimes to
create new businesses or IKEA in Sweden
or let's take the classic example of
Toyota in Japan or in its plants all
around the world in fact Toyota's model
of so called
lean production is the source of many of
the ideas and practices that need to be
fitted together in high road firms to
achieve world-class productivity quality
and good jobs we're gonna see in another
video my colleague zeinab thanh talking
about a grocery chain here in the
northeastern part of the United States
that has been very successful in
building a company that works for
shareholders
as well as customers and employees and
in fact the employees and managers
revolted to save the company from a
change in strategy in the summer of 2014
so let's get on with the task of
building these high road
good jobs companies or if you're not in
a top management position at the moment
demanding that your employer follow
these principles wherever you happen to
live and work that's the challenge you
face not only in creating these but
spreading these to become the norm
across American industry
you